DAVE RENSIN: I am very, very
excited for this next panel.
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Dave Rensin.
I am a Google SRE running
Customer Reliability
Engineering, and I am
super excited for us
to have a conversation
about some
of the weird, wild, and
just plain wacky things
that we have seen over the last
10 or 11 years in Google SRE.
And really excited to have
the people joining us today.
So welcome to the 5th Nine.
Settle in, enjoy your
lunches and your beverages,
and we're going to kick off.
A little later there'll be a
little audience participation.
I made some notes
because I want to make
sure my introductions
are correct.
So first, I would
like to welcome
George Sadlier to the stage.
Come on up, George.
George is a 10-year Googler.
He has worked in about every
corner of SRE you can imagine,
from ads, to BigQuery,
to Chrome, to Dremel,
which most of you will know
externally as BigQuery,
and we are honored
to have him here.
Next, Steve Carstensen.
Steve, come on up.
Steve runs network
infrastructure SRE at Google.
Basically, his team is
responsible for the health
of our production network.
And, you know, when it catches
fire, which occasionally it
will do, they're the ones
who run in to fix it.
Our third panelist today,
I thought would be fun,
is John Welsh.
John, come on up.
John's done a bunch
of things at Google,
most notably working
on cloud reliability.
But the thing I think
makes him most interesting
for this is his other job,
as he runs a thing called
DRT, Disaster Recovery Testing.
So basically, Steve
and George are
responsible for fixing
things and making
sure things are operating
right when they break,
and getting things
back up and running.
John's job is to
proactively break
things to make sure that we can
respond in a reasonable way.
And I thought that might be
kind of an interesting mix.
So, if you'll
please, a quick round
of applause for our
panelists, and we
will kick off some of this.
[APPLAUSE]
George, I want to
start with you.
If that's OK, we'll
just pass a mic around.
I have a "Farmer's
Almanac" in my house
that I bought lo, these many
years ago when I was a kid.
And in the front, it's
got a set of things
that every farmer knows is true.
And one of them is that
lightning never strikes twice
in the same place.
And what I want
to know from you,
George, is, were they
full of it when they
wrote that, or were they right?
GEORGE SADLIER:
I'm not sure what
the science is on the matter.
Unfortunately, observed evidence
proves it to be a false.
We've certainly
experienced multiple--
I'm being signaled to
keep it close to my--
OK.
That better?
Cool.
We've certainly experienced
somewhat multiple strikes
in quick succession.
We had a particular
scenario in the last year
in Belgium, where
we had actually--
it was a half dozen strikes
in fairly rapid succession
over a couple of
minutes striking
the electrical grid supporting
one of our facilities.
Which caused some interesting--
I mean, obviously,
these facilities are
designed to survive power loss.
And so yeah, the grid
went out and we went on
to emergency power,
but it was interesting
because those systems kicked
in, carried the facility,
went back off again because
the power was restored.
And then we went back
onto emergency power,
and then off, and
then on, and then off,
resulting in much drama
and entertainment,
mostly because I think we
thought the systems were
malfunctioning.
DAVE RENSIN: [INAUDIBLE] so--
[TAPPING MICROPHONE]
Nada.
GEORGE SADLIER: Dave.
DAVE RENSIN: That's OK.
No?
OK, cool.
Give me something?
CREW: Microphone.
DAVE RENSIN: Cool.
I'm good.
OK, so as I recall,
right, there were
a bunch of strikes up and down.
It was us, and the substation,
and the power provider,
and then back, and then--
like kind of a
ping pong-y thing.
This is not a thing
we plan for, right?
There is no plausible
computer model
where that pattern of lightning
strikes makes any sense,
but still we muddled
our way through it.
Can you talk a little
bit, just at a high level,
about planning and the
general principles of defense,
in depth, that let us survive
what is, frankly, a completely
unpredictable sort of a thing?
GEORGE SADLIER: Yeah, I mean,
like any large-scale data
center facility, we've
got extensive backup power
in place.
We've got standby generators
ready to come on at no notice.
We've got the battery
backup systems to cover us
during that transition.
We don't expect that
type of scenario,
but at the end of the day, any
power outage is a power outage,
and we were able to
cover through it.
Most of the drama in
that particular instance
was unrelated to the
multiple strikes,
but more came down to a
software glitch in our battery
controllers, which caused a
little bit more drama than we
really needed that
particular day, resulting
in some loss of power to
some racks, which we did not
appreciate.
DAVE RENSIN: All right, Steve,
let me ask you something.
So the other day, I was reading
my most reliable internet
conspiracy theory sites,
because, as we know,
everything's very
reliable in the internet,
and I stumbled on
something I thought maybe
you could comment on.
My understanding is that they
actually make underwater fiber
cables out of fish food.
I wonder if you could
tell me about that.
STEVE CARSTENSEN: Sure, although
it's not really fish food,
and we don't really
know why, but it is true
that sharks do like
to chew on the cables
that we run the
internet through,
the networking through,
under the ocean.
Google actually wraps its--
well, according to
stories I have read,
I actually don't have
personal knowledge here--
Google has a patent
on fiber that we--
or fabric that we wrap
around the cables,
that we might wrap around
the cables to protect them
from shark attacks, but I don't
know if we actually do that.
That was a different
internet company
that that story was about.
But we have a lot of
animal-related outages
of one form or another.
Now, most of these don't
actually cause outages.
They just cause problems.
We had a case in Atlanta
a number of years ago
where a snake got into I believe
it was a power transformer
station and shorted
out part of the grid
at that data center,
which was exciting.
We've had birds flying
into transmission lines.
We've had, in one case, a
fiber that we leased in Brazil,
was cut by somebody who was
digging a hole to bury a horse.
We've had all sorts of
fiber and network outages
and power outages
related to things.
DAVE RENSIN: OK, so cat
videos notwithstanding,
animals are not always
big fans of the internet,
as it turns out.
STEVE CARSTENSEN:
They're one of the things
you have to deal with.
DAVE RENSIN: All right,
John, I've always
wanted to ask you this in
all the time I've known you.
So your job, as I
understand it, is
to cause problems for
production teams in production.
To break things and either
tell them ahead of time or not.
What I want to know is, you're
like the most popular person
at Google, right?
I assume you eat alone,
maybe under armed guard.
How does that work?
JOHN WELSH: I try to
keep a low profile.
But yeah, so we manage the
Disaster Recovery Testing
program.
We call it "dirt" for short.
And it's a program to,
in a very controlled way,
find issues within our systems,
break them, and recover
from them.
And the recovery is
obviously very important,
and we always want to
do this in a way that
isn't customer facing.
So, yeah, we're
always out there.
We run continuously year round.
And then we have like these
company-wide disaster recovery
testing week events so--
DAVE RENSIN: And
then without using
names, because I
don't want you to,
tell me in the world of
cloud, the reliability
is not just what
we're offering, it's
what our customers
are bringing to it.
Do we ever do DRT
with our customers?
JOHN WELSH: Yeah.
Yeah, we've certainly done
tests with other companies
in a very, again,
controlled way.
Everything from looking
at incident management,
maybe you have an issue
with your systems running
on our cloud, and you
need to escalate that
into Google support for cloud,
and so how would we do that?
And how do those issues go
from your system, your product,
through to our support, to our
engineers, and get resolved?
It's something we
want to practice
and make sure we have good
and effective communication.
We want to make sure
that we can find issues
with your systems, the
software that you're
relying on within the platform.
DAVE RENSIN: Allie,
where are you?
OK, so, we have an audience.
I thought maybe it'd
be an interesting idea
if we took questions.
It's always a little--
it's live, so who knows?
We'll see what we get.
If you want to ask a question
about some of this stuff,
or other reliability things,
just give a quick signal
to Allie and we can do that.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
DAVE RENSIN: Wow, a shy crowd.
I do see we have in
the crowd Bart Fromm,
the mysterious and
amazing Bart Fromm.
Bart is the director of cloud
reliability for all of Google.
Come on up here, Bart, so we
can embarrass you a little bit.
BART FROMM: All right.
So why don't we talk about--
I guess the one I think we
should talk about from a DRT
perspective, is
how large of scale
we try and do the DRT tests out?
Are they small tests?
Are they large tests?
Give people a sense of how
thorough we go into that.
JOHN WELSH: Yeah,
sure, absolutely.
So, thanks, Bart.
So we run tests at a team
level, so individual teams.
But we also run them
across large systems.
So, for example,
we have done tests
where we power cycle a
production data center.
So this is not like just
hitting the Restart button
on the desktop under you.
There's lots of
playing that goes
into it, many, many complex
systems that we have to plan,
mitigations.
And try to understand the best
way that we expect it to fail
and be prepared.
And so, of course, you can
imagine, all these systems--
services are running
within the data center.
We take a lot of
precautions to make sure
that they're out of the
way and to make sure
that SRE can rebalance
that load of those services
across the other data centers.
At scale, I think that's one
of the largest, is shutting off
an entire data center and
turning it back on again.
That's pretty large.
BART FROMM: Steve,
we were earlier
talking about problems
we run into with fiber.
Can you talk about
the redundancy
that we build into each
building or into each campus,
so that we're not stuck when
a shark or a boat's anchor
rips through one
of our fiber lines?
STEVE CARSTENSEN: Sure.
The way we design our network
involves multiple paths
between all of our
points of presence
and our [INAUDIBLE]
data centers.
So a single fiber
cut should never
cause us a problem, although,
of course, there are exceptions.
We provision the way--
the networking is
sized to be resilient
in the face of any individual
component going offline,
either within the data
center or outside.
This means that most of the
time when we have fiber cuts--
and we have fiber
cuts all the time--
no one notices.
Most of the time when there is
a customer-visible or even just
Google service-visible
outage, it's
a result of five or six or
seven or 10 concurrent events.
Some fiber cut, some router
down, some other issues.
And even in those
cases, we've usually
been able to recover
service, in advance
of the systems that
broke being put back
into service, by routing
traffic better or in a more
intelligent fashion.
BART FROMM: Sorry,
I'm being told
to move away from the speaker
because I'm creating feedback.
One last question around
the network pieces.
Obviously, we're a
very large network.
One of the things Eric's
talked about was the size.
Can you talk about how
much we see with regards
to when we get DDoS attack?
Like, how big of an issue
it is that we feel like we
get versus what actually
ends up happening.
STEVE CARSTENSEN: I can say
that, in the recent past,
the majority of botnets
that we are aware of
do not cause Google
services problems.
We are pretty sure
that there are
larger botnets in the world
that have not attacked us,
so I don't want to say
we are immune, because we
are definitely not immune.
But as far as we can tell, DDoS
attacks we see in the wild,
either directed to us or
that we see backscatter from,
we believe we would
be able to cope with.
And certainly the ones that
actually have attacked us,
we've been able to
cope with quite well.
DAVE RENSIN: All right, let
me shift here for a quick sec.
George, you do a ton
of reviews with teams.
You do a ton of interviewing.
In all the time that you've
looked at stuff, if there
was just one thing out of the
canon of reliability principles
that you wished everybody
did, what is it?
GEORGE SADLIER: Can we let Steve
tell my favorite story first?
DAVE RENSIN: OK, tell
George's favorite story.
I don't know what that is.
What is that, Steve?
STEVE CARSTENSEN:
All right, so this
is a story about a major
outage we had a few years ago.
It was actually not an outage.
It's one of my favorite sort
of outages, it was a near miss.
Just a bit of background about
the Google infrastructure.
Most of our computers
are in data centers,
which are typically pretty
far from where our users are.
In order to improve the
experience of Google customers,
we run a large fleet
of dedicated servers
on the edge of our network
that do load balancing, TCP
determination, SSL
termination, et cetera.
This is also within
Google's network,
all within Google's
control, but out
sort of in our points appearing
at the edge of the network.
So these edge nodes are
different from our normal data
centers.
So they have their
own set of automation,
turn up, turn down, et cetera.
And a couple of years
ago, one of the engineers
who was working on the turn
up, turn down automation
specifically for
these edge nodes
was exercising a new
pathway, a new particular way
of doing something.
And he was mistakenly
under the impression
that the turn down
automation was idempotent.
That is, if you ran it
twice on the same thing,
nothing new would happen.
Unfortunately, he was wrong.
So first, he ran
at once, testing
on a particular workflow,
a particular step that
sends all the machines
in a particular edge
node to something we
call disk erase, which
is when we erase all the disks
as part of doing turn down.
And that worked just fine.
It was a satellite that was
already going out of service.
There was a bug
with the workflow.
So we ran it again on
the same satellite.
Unfortunately, the way that this
actually worked is, you say,
I want to run this thing
on this set of machines.
And the way you get
this set of machines,
very briefly, is
you basically say,
I want all of the machines that
fit this particular pattern.
Unfortunately, the result of
"no machines match this pattern"
is not "no machines,"
it's "all machines."
We have seen this
failure many times
in very, very
different scenarios,
but anytime you interpret
an input as everything,
you should really
think carefully
about what you're doing.
Because of the
layers here, no one
really understood
that this is the way
that this would be interpreted.
The upshot was this engineer
accidentally called disk erase
on every edge node in the
fleet at the same time.
Another funny, to
me, side note, is
my team, who runs the edge
nodes, didn't at that time
believe disk erase
worked on the edge nodes.
Like, we just thought
that it should work,
we hadn't gotten it to work.
We thought, it probably
just wouldn't do anything.
It turns out, we were
horribly, hilariously wrong.
In the course of
about 20 minutes,
every edge node in the
fleet lost its mind,
lost all of its configs and
binaries, and stopped serving.
Now, you didn't hear about
this because the way we design,
the way we do front-end
serving, involves
as seamless failover as we can.
TCP connections
were reset, so there
was some spike of new
connections being formed,
but all of the traffic,
relatively seamlessly,
failed over to the
back-end data centers
where we have reserve capacity.
There was also some
congestion on our backbone
and with our peers.
Because of the
details of how we do
BGP, when we terminate
TCP connections in data
centers versus
our edge nodes, it
changes where the bits
egress from our network.
And so some of our
peers were congested,
and we had to do various traffic
engineering on our backbone
in order to resolve that.
But for the most
part, no one noticed.
And no one noticed over
the next 48 to 72 hours
as my team put together--
basically everyone on the team--
into two 12-hour
shifts in the Bay Area
and in London, trying very,
very hard to put the edge back
into place as fast as we could.
We ran into all sorts
of problems doing this.
But again-- and I can talk about
this if somebody wanted me to--
the upshot is, defense in
depth is a very useful thing.
No one noticed.
We were really lucky
that we found this out
in this particular scenario.
It turns out this exact
piece of automation
could have done the same
thing to a different class
of machines that would have
been far far, far worse.
So, in a way, we're really
lucky we did it to the edge.
And we had a tremendously
awesome postmortem internally.
It was a great
bonding experience,
I think, for the team.
And it still is a story
that we talk about,
because it's a very formative
outage, well, near miss.
DAVE RENSIN: And there are
times where defense in depth,
in a weird way, is not
your friend, unless it's
accompanied by testing.
And I recall we had
an incident where--
we've talked about this
publicly-- where we pushed
a bad route, that BGP route.
And, because there
was so much capacity
for network in so many
different places globally,
what happened was is,
if you can imagine
a map of all these connections
of where packets could
come in and go out
of our network,
as the route was
propagating they
were just going dark
one after the other.
But it took us a while
to notice because we
have fiber connecting all these
things, and it's very fast,
and there's so much capacity
that the traffic was just
being moved to other
parts of the network.
And you didn't see
it in the latency.
You didn't see it in
the characteristics
you would expect.
And we kind of didn't
really feel the effect
until essentially-- it's a
little bit of hyperbole--
the last node went out.
Like, the last exit to the door
closed, and then the whole flow
stopped for a few minutes.
That was the case,
I think, where
the redundancy and
the defense in depth
was good, but not necessarily
accompanied by the right kind
of monitoring.
STEVE CARSTENSEN: Absolutely.
And we've had variations of that
outage at other times as well.
I mean, the lesson is,
defense in depth is great,
but you want to know
when you start using
other layers of your defense.
And that was our
problem here, is
that the particular monitoring
in the scenario that Dave
is talking about was
not precise enough
to tell us that
individual locations were
no longer attracting traffic.
All we could tell, at
that point in time,
all our monitoring told us was
that traffic was still getting
through to the back ends,
until suddenly it wasn't.
DAVE RENSIN: OK, George,
you demurred to Steve
when I asked you the question.
We're not letting
you off the hook.
GEORGE SADLIER: Can
we tell more stories?
DAVE RENSIN: By all means.
Tell them.
GEORGE SADLIER:
Because we've got time.
We've got stories.
DAVE RENSIN: Yeah, don't worry.
Go on.
GEORGE SADLIER: I
was going to say,
this is a classic
set of failure modes.
We had an interesting outage
in a system we will not name,
near outage, where
our configuration
change was rolling out.
Which was at an
upstream system, which
we were mostly not aware of
because we didn't need to know.
But we we had a low traffic
alarm from one of our clusters
because we a traffic levels,
and these clusters of pretty
are pretty busy.
So when we didn't get any
traffic in the cluster,
that was cause for
an alert to go off.
And we're, what's going on?
Let's go look.
OK, there's no traffic.
And as we're
debugging that traffic
to figure out what's
wrong with that cluster,
another alarm goes off
in another cluster.
And it's like, oh no.
And now we are
frantically debugging
because, as we're
watching out maps,
we're watching traffic
dropping offline in no order we
can determine, as
traffic vanishes
from front-end serving clusters.
And at some point,
somebody in the team
made the connection
that was following
the exact pattern of
the Google front end,
it's one of our
front-end proxy systems
and it's config [INAUDIBLE].
Which happens to be
one of Steve's teams.
So we reached out in
a panic, and begged
them to stop their push
while we figured out
what on earth had gone wrong.
And sure enough, somebody
who will not be named--
STEVE CARSTENSEN:
Blameless postmortems,
blameless postmortems.
GEORGE SADLIER:
--had made a typo--
DAVE RENSIN: Blaming,
which just identified him.
GEORGE SADLIER: Yeah.
Had made a typo
in a config change
and it had been reviewed
by numerous people, none
of whom had spotted the typo.
And so as the conflict went
out, the front end conveniently
forgot the particular
back end in question
and stopped sending
traffic to it.
When we halted it
with one cluster left.
Just one.
And so we processed
all of our global load
on one cluster for
24 hours before we
could get that corrected.
This was quite a while ago.
It was a lot harder to
roll back those systems.
These days, we could
roll back very quickly.
In those days, it was
a bit more of a journey
to achieve rollback.
And so we decided that
it was actually safer
to stay in place, because
we were doing all right.
It was running slower
than it needed to,
but it was
functioning correctly.
So we could hold out
24 hours until we
could get a safe rollback.
So much fun and games.
JOHN WELSH: Both
George and Steve, you
guys both mentioned
postmortem culture.
Maybe George, you
want to elaborate
on what that means for us?
GEORGE SADLIER: I'm assuming
everyone's read the book,
so they know all
about postmortems.
No, I mean, we really--
this is what we consider one
of the key principles of Cyber
Reliability Engineering and just
good reliability engineering
in general.
The idea that, if
you're moving quickly,
you're working on big,
complicated systems.
These large-scale
distributed systems
have emergent properties.
Things are going to happen
that you couldn't predict.
Things are going to go wrong.
People are going
to make mistakes.
And the ability
and the willingness
to go back and
thoroughly understand
what happened so you can
determine how to prevent
it happening again, and
learn from the outage,
is super important.
But the only way you can have
a culture that really does that
is by endorsing
that blameless part.
Right?
Humans make mistakes.
It's what we do.
Humans are excellent
at making mistakes.
If you want something
to not make a mistake,
you use silicon.
The problem is, the silicon
is programmed by humans.
And what did I just
say about humans?
So we have to be willing
to go in with no blame.
It's going to happen.
We're going to introduce bugs.
Software engineers write bugs.
We're quite good at that.
System's going to fail
in unexpected ways.
If we were expecting humans to
never make mistakes, you fail.
Human's going to make mistakes.
If you've got a process
that requires a human
not to make a mistake, you're
going to have an outage.
And so, sitting back,
and looking at that,
and understanding that
is really important.
And so you've got to have
the blameless postmortem,
the willingness to go
back and look at it.
STEVE CARSTENSEN:
And on that note,
one of the most
important things,
in my opinion, at least, about
a blameless postmortem culture
is not blaming the human
even in the actions.
So when you're thinking about,
how do I avoid this problem?
It is a mistake if
you say, the way
I will avoid this problem
is by just training
the humans better, or by
teaching the humans to do
something more intelligent,
or by updating the procedure
that the human uses.
Maybe you should do
all of those things,
but that's not
actually a root cause.
The way you should
look at an outage,
and the postmortem
about an outage,
is identify why the
system allowed the human
to make the mistake.
You should fix the system
so the human cannot do that.
GEORGE SADLIER: Yeah.
I think there's a
classic example of this
from quite some time ago now.
There was an outage
in a web mail system
where, ultimately, the trigger
for the incident was a human.
A human pushed a change.
And the human in question--
he was a friend of mine--
was very upset.
He had felt that
he had personally
caused an outage, a major outage
that basically all of Google's
users had experienced.
But the reality is, is he
was working through a change
process to change--
it was actually a contact
management system--
to change the way the
available back ends
for the contact
management system
and how they were served.
And this system had gotten
a lot more complicated.
I'm at system
scale very quickly.
And so a process that
kind of made sense
when there were
two or three nodes
didn't really make
nearly as much sense
when we would go to a 300.
And so the process
required a human
to review a machine-readable
dataset and the diffs on it
and make sure that
it was correct.
That was the control.
Human should review
diff and approve it.
This happens a couple
of times a week.
And you know what?
99.9% of the time
there's nothing there.
So of course, the human looks
at it, looks about right,
moves on.
And we can sit back
and we can say, hey,
they should have
been more careful.
But that's ridiculous, right?
It's the classic thing of,
like, 90% of the job is boring
and one second of
absolute terror.
It's when the thing
is almost always
right except when it's not,
humans are a terrible choice,
right?
Human mental pattern
matching does not
function in that environment.
So the engineer did what
every other engineer
in their position would do, and
they looked at the diff, looks
about right, off it went.
And left that system with
insufficient serving capacity,
which triggered a cascading
failure of that contact
management system,
which, in turn, caused
severe consequences
further up the stack.
There's many problems here.
A failure in the contact
management system
shouldn't prevent
access to your email.
But that process had not
scaled with the system.
And the idea that somehow
this engineer was at fault
is ridiculous.
That outage was
guaranteed the moment
we put that process in place.
All right, the fault
there was not the humans.
Didn't matter what human was
at the keyboard that day.
If it didn't happen that day,
it would happen the day after.
It could have happened
the month before.
That outage was inevitable.
It's not the human.
Human just happened to be
the person on the keyboard.
And so another example is
really important to remember,
we were asking a
human to do something
that humans are not good at.
The failure was in the
process and the technology.
There should have been a--
the machines should
have been checking that.
The machines should have been
doing velocity checking, which
is basically a
technique we're saying,
this is the expected size of any
change in this configuration.
If it's larger than this, stop.
But we didn't do that.
JOHN WELSH: So you
touched on something
about looking at the
assumptions of the system.
And so that's one
of the main things
we do when we do disaster
testing is challenge
assumptions about systems.
Especially long-held
So maybe you have a backup.
Well, we always
back our data up.
Of course it's good.
Of course we can restore it.
Why would there
ever be a problem?
So I would come along
and I would say,
we really should test
that backup and restore.
And we should look at the
integrity of that data
because your data isn't actually
useful unless you can use it.
Right?
So having a backup
is just one thing.
Being able to restore it
and use it is another thing.
And maybe failing
over it, right?
I have, oh, I'm in multiple
zones, multiple regions.
Well, actually go and
test your systems,
and drain a zone, or whatnot,
so that you can actually
validate practically that these
assumptions work correctly
in different failure modes
and different scenarios.
DAVE RENSIN: I'm
newer to Google.
I haven't been here as
long as you guys have.
And I remember, not
long after I joined,
someone was explaining to be
blameless postmortem culture.
And I was skeptical.
Because I've worked at other
companies, and the first thing
you do is you blame someone.
And I remember I had this
conversation with George.
I was in Seattle.
And I said, you know,
that sounds good,
but I don't believe you.
And he said, oh, really?
And I don't remember who
this was, and even if I did,
I wouldn't use their name.
He's like, come here.
And he walked me
over to someone,
and he said, hi, this is Dave.
Tell Dave, when were
you last promoted?
And the person told him,
it's been six months ago.
And he said, why'd
you get promoted?
He said, well, I
broke something.
All right, what?
That seems the opposite of
the way that normally works.
Please use more words.
And he said, oh, well,
what happened was is,
I was doing a thing,
and I made a mistake.
I made a mistake and I broke it.
And that was bad.
And then, so then of
course, I fixed it.
And then I wrote the postmortem.
And then I built software
so the system wouldn't
allow the next unlucky
person, who happened to be me,
to break it the same way again.
And it turned out to be a bunch
more work than people thought
it would be, because it was a
complicated thing because it
was a big emergent system.
And lo and behold, the
company was like, great,
that is working as intended.
You just happened to be
the unlucky person who
made the mistake that someone
was eventually going to make,
you raised your hand, you
fixed it, you led the process,
you built the software.
Now another person can't
make that mistake again.
You're promoted.
And I just remember, that was
the thing that really stuck
with me, was that conversation.
GEORGE SADLIER: I
was actually going
to come back, because I think
a point John just made about--
there's an old adage in
systems administration.
Your backups are only as
good as your restores.
And one of the things that came
out of one of John's DRT tests
on one of my systems is, we'd
done a bunch restore testing.
And we knew we could restore.
Restores were great.
They work fantastically,
they're pretty quick.
And then the DRT team showed
up and said, OK, well, we
know you can do
account restores.
Let's restore the entire system.
And we're like,
sure, no problem.
Get the thing kicked
off, get it running,
it's running a bit slow.
Estimated completion date--
2119.
Not the time, the year.
And it was like, oh, yeah,
each individual restore was
pretty quick, but we
hadn't actually sat down
and run the numbers.
And it turns out, because of the
way the storage system worked--
it was a random access
and some other things--
the time between account
restores was pretty long,
and the result was
we'd never tried to--
we'd done individual restores
and we'd done batch restores,
but we'd never tried to
restore a really big group.
And that was the only time
we realized that, actually,
if we ever needed to
do a complete restore,
we were not going be able to.
And that was a result
of one of the folks
that John works with coming
to us and just saying,
can you do this?
And us saying, of course we can.
We'll test it.
OK, we'll test it.
It'll be fun.
So anyway, short story
is, we promptly rewrote
our restore system to do a lot
of our restores in parallel.
Strangely enough, made
a huge difference.
And now it restores much,
much, much, much, much faster.
But I still remember
the email coming
across saying, yeah, no, we'll
be done in about 200 years.
I was going to say, there must
be some other funny stories
have come out of DRT tests.
DAVE RENSIN: That was the other
thing I was going to ask you,
John.
So you sit in a
privileged position.
Not only to see wacky
things, but to cause them,
to make them happen.
So I'll give you a
choice, fielder's choice,
and then we're going to
play a game of topper.
But I'll tell you,
explain that in a second.
So what is either
the craziest thing
you caused, either on purpose
or not on purpose, or just
the craziest thing you have
seen as a part of doing DRT?
I want to hear this.
JOHN WELSH: That I
can talk about, right?
DAVE RENSIN: Yeah.
Yeah, right, keeping in mind,
I'm sorry, keeping in mind
we're in the middle of Google's
semiannual performance review
season.
So you just want to hold that
in the back of your head.
JOHN WELSH: Right,
right, of course, yeah.
Yeah, so I think
probably a good story is,
so I mentioned earlier that we
have a company-wide disaster
recovery test week event.
So we're running several
hundred tests over a week.
A lot of them are very
disruptive to ourselves, not
to our customers, ideally.
And this one particular
cycle we got about halfway
through the week and
we're planning scenarios.
We have kind of a story
that goes along with it.
Like, maybe an asteroid
is hitting the Bay Area,
or maybe some storm is
affecting the East Coast.
So it turns out about
halfway through the week,
a large winter storm actually
did occur and impacted
the southeast US,
which wasn't great.
Some places had reduced
staffing, things like that.
On top of that,
on the West Coast,
we had a real fiber
cut that coincided.
And so that was OK.
That's fine, one fiber
cut, no big deal.
But then, on the East Coast, in
a totally separate data center,
we had a network
line card failure.
And OK, fine, a little
bit of additional latency.
We're still OK.
Let's get a card shipped
out there and replaced.
That card was dead on arrival.
Now there's this winter storm.
It now is going to take
FedEx or UPS or whatever
it was an additional two
days to get a line card.
So now, we're going to
need to recalibrate and say
we're going to run with a
bit of additional latency
for longer than maybe we would
have liked, but that's OK.
We're still working on it,
working through things.
All right, we're still
running our tests.
We were running a test of one of
our storage layers in one area.
And nearby, there was an
unexpected power event
that affected the storage
layer that we were testing
in a different
location that reduced
their available capacity.
So we're kind of like piling on
with all these real situations.
So I think the thing
that surprised me most
was that here we are
planning these disasters
and trying to do
disaster testing,
and all these real events are
occurring at the same time.
Sort of, if you think it, it
will happen kind of problem.
So we paused our tests, we
rolled back certain tests.
And we totally changed the
dynamic of our war room.
So we took our team of
experts, and instead
of trying to cause
issues, we started
to help resolve the issues.
So we helped with
incident management.
We helped the teams
that were directly
trying to address
some of these issues.
We could do troubleshooting.
We could actually fix some of
the issues for some of them
in some cases and help get
everything back together.
So I think what surprised
me is the way that--
don't panic when disaster
occurs, because it will occur.
Keep a cool head, invoke your
incident management protocols,
lend a hand, and a were very
creative and very supportive
in helping get
everything back up
and running very quickly
and very successfully.
So as someone who is
trying to cause problems
in a constructive
way, it was very
cool and surprising to see
us actually pull together
and fix things in a big way.
GEORGE SADLIER: And
being on the receiving
end of a lot of that
testing, I remember
a couple of
brainstorming sessions
as we're getting ready
for our annual testing.
And we're sitting
there saying, OK,
well, let's work through
our emergency procedures
and figure out what we
want to test this year.
And I said, well,
we'll test that one.
Oh, yeah, we actually did that
a month ago because it happened.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, no, we did that
one recently, too.
Oh.
Actually we've tested everything
so far in the last six months
because everything has broken
at some point or another.
And we had to come up with some
particularly creative and crazy
tests because it's
like, yeah, no.
I mean, it turns out there's
two types of emergencies.
There's routine emergencies
and emergent emergencies.
And we're pretty good
at routine emergencies.
JOHN WELSH: I mean, I think
you raise an interesting point,
too, which is that we like
to look at the systems,
and test the systems, and try
to make them fall tolerant,
but there's also humans
involved, right, as you
were talking about earlier.
So practicing incident
management is really important.
Being able to
quickly invoke people
to respond to the incident.
That they have muscle
memory there is a big deal.
A lot of times at Google we
have a very horizontal structure
with people and management.
So when we have an
incident, we tend
to invoke this
incident management
protocol that's
more hierarchical,
because the scenario
calls for it.
You need someone who
can call the shots.
You need people who are
feeding them information.
You need people to
do communications
and troubleshoot.
And that needs to be able to
expand or shrink depending
on the scale of the disaster.
And that's a little
bit unusual for how
we would run the day to day.
And so practicing that
over and over again
and being prepared on the human
side makes a huge difference.
Ideally, your systems can
self-heal and defend and things
like that but--
GEORGE SADLIER: I mean,
Steve and I both sit
on our global technical
incident response team dealing
with the largest events.
But I remember a good couple
of years ago now, during DRT,
because DRT, of course, is one
of the most stressful times
of the incident response team.
Because we want to
make like this is real.
But we're taking events
that, in the real world,
the narrative would
span over a month maybe,
and we can press it down
to like three or four days.
And I remember a couple
of days that week where
I was the incident commander
for the global environment,
and I think simultaneously I had
three data centers on emergency
power, one under simulated
terrorist attack,
the Bay Area was under
water, and something
was going on in Europe.
And so I just had
my white board just
covered in, like, current status
and runtimes of facilities.
And I've got various
operations leads
running these
individual incidents
as I try and keep track of it.
And because of the simulated
outage at headquarters,
I supposedly have no
fallback to executives.
And so it's just like,
we'll keep production up
as long we can.
But it was quite the test of our
incident management capability.
STEVE CARSTENSEN: I mean, the
great thing about that is I
never have that experience,
because I work in the Bay Area,
and inevitably, in DRT
week, they tell us,
oh, you're under water.
You're part of the disaster.
So the rest of the
world has to take over.
GEORGE SADLIER: Yeah,
I'm based in Seattle,
so whenever that happens,
everyone looks at me.
And one or two of my
colleagues on the East Coast.
DAVE RENSIN: Okay, I want
to be mindful of time here.
I want to wrap up with this.
All right, so John,
we heard from you.
Steve, I want to know, what is
either the strangest incident
you have caused, Steve
Carstensen has caused,
or that you've been a part
of, that you can talk about?
STEVE CARSTENSEN: Oh.
DAVE RENSIN: I know there are
so many from which to choose.
STEVE CARSTENSEN: I'm having
a hard time right now.
Uh-- I mean, the
edge note outage.
So our edge nodes are
internally culled satellites,
so the edge node outage is
known internally as Satpocalypse
because it's when we
destroyed all the satellites.
That was one of my
favorite outages.
I'm trying to think
of another one
that I can actually talk about.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STEVE CARSTENSEN: Sorry?
STEVE CARSTENSEN: That was
actually before my time, sir.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE SADLIER: I can do mine.
STEVE CARSTENSEN: All right.
DAVE RENSIN: Let George go.
STEVE CARSTENSEN: I don't
know anything about it all.
George, it's his.
GEORGE SADLIER: I
was going to say,
it wasn't an outage per se, but
we had a particularly hilarious
internal outage.
So much as you know, we
have a pretty impressive
infrastructure.
Got a lot of software engineers
doing a lot of cool stuff,
but we've got
legacy systems, too.
To be fair, the company's
only about 15 years old, so--
well, 20 years now, but--
not that legacy, but we had
one particular internal system
within the ads environment
where we saw stored session
state for some front ends.
Back when we thought
that was a good idea.
We don't-- general
rule of thumb,
try to avoid session
state if you ever can.
But we had session
state, and we needed
to flush it into the
storage back ends in order
to ensure that session state
would be retained if we had
a fault. If there was a
failure of our front end,
we could keep session
state on a different node.
And this was ancient,
ancient code.
We have whole RPC
environments now
which handle internal
communication,
but this predates all of them.
So it was a very
primitive system,
and we'd never
really felt the need
to upgrade it because it worked.
And then one day,
the nodes start
failing on us, the
session state service.
And we can't figure out why.
They are just falling
over, globally.
Not all at once,
but sequentially,
and just patterned
down, and just failing.
And so we're all frantically
looking, because we're worried.
It's working, because these
things are multiply redundant,
objects are getting passed
between nodes, and so
no user-visible problems.
But if we lose
many more at once--
because they restart quickly--
we're going to have a problem.
So we're all freaking
out, because we're
trying to figure out
what on earth is going
wrong with these things before
it worsens and we actually
have an outage.
And we discover
they're all going out
of memory, which is
weird because they really
don't do very much.
And we dig through
the logs, and we're
having a heck of a time finding
logs because guess what?
You usually write
logs when you're
done writing a request,
done processing a request.
If you crash while
you're processing it,
you don't always
get a log entry.
So we're frantically searching.
We think we've got a query
of death, which is basically
some combination of
traffic at the front end
is making its way
through and knocking over
any back end it hits.
So we're trying dump out traffic
and figure out what's going on.
And then we notice that,
when they go out of memory,
they always request precisely
the same amount of memory.
So it's 4 gig or so of RAM or
whatever they were requesting,
and it was like it was
taking them out of memory.
It was always exactly
the same number.
And it was suspicious.
The number was not
special in any way
except it was always the same.
And so we're like, OK, clearly
query of death, clearly
query of death.
We're digging around, we can't
figure out what's going on.
And the failure rate stabilized,
and we can't figure out
what's going on.
And then an amazing
intuitive leap.
One of the engineers on the
team just sits back in his chair
and says something I won't
repeat on live camera
and then just writes up
on the board four dashes,
and on top of them
writes G-E-T space.
That was the ASCII
coding of the DSML number
that was being allocated.
And so what was happening is one
of the early spiders in Google
production was sweeping through
production, connecting to ports
and sending a get, as you
do, because most things
at Google speak
HTTP, unsurprisingly.
Except these machines didn't.
They ran a very
primitive protocol,
and the first 32
bits of the packet
were the size of the
object being allocated.
So when you connected to that
port and you said get slash,
it interpreted the
get space in DSML
as the size of the
object that followed.
So of course, the
first thing it did
was it tried to allocate that
much memory, couldn't, failed.
So we just sat around the
room laughing our asses off
for about half an hour before
we pushed an emergency fix
to input check.
DAVE RENSIN: All right,
Steve, you've had a reprieve.
We've got about a minute left.
STEVE CARSTENSEN: All right.
So there's too
many to pick from,
but this is a more recent
event, a year or two ago.
And I pick it mostly
because I was actually
on call for this event.
I'm on call, I got a
huge passel of pages,
because an IP
address that is used
for domain resolution external
to Google, one of our DNS-VIPS,
was being block hold.
And all of our monitoring
was alerting and saying
horrible, horrible things.
And so I get paged.
I start frantically
trying to debug,
trying to figure
out what's going on.
I eventually figure out that
the traffic is successfully
coming into our backbone,
it's crossing our backbone,
it's getting to some
of the locations
where we host this IP address.
We're looking, we're
looking, we're looking.
And then eventually, through
a chain that I can't really
summarize, chain of events,
one of my teammates and I
figure out that what
is actually happening
is one of our internal systems
that is a defense system
to deal with DDoS
attacks has been
enabled on this particular IP.
And it's at that point
that we discovered
that this was
actually a DRT test
to see whether we would notice
and how fast we would figure it
out.
Because it turns out that
the way that this all works,
this particular IP address
was not actually important.
Clients just seamlessly failover
to one of the other NS-VIPS,
and so the impact was zero,
except to my heartbeat.
DAVE RENSIN: Your sanity, yeah.
STEVE CARSTENSEN:
It was good times.
We did figure it out in
what, like, 20 minutes?
Yeah.
DAVE RENSIN: OK,
so on that note.
A quick announcement.
Remember, everyone, 5
o'clock this evening,
happy hour here in the 5th Nine
lounge for those of you who
are in person and at the event.
We'll be joined by Home Depot.
They're going to have a bunch
of really interesting things
to say.
But just this moment,
please, a round
of applause for our panelists
John Welsh, Steve Carstensen,
and George Sadlier.
[APPLAUSE]